are you not entertained  are you not entertained Ridley had been  you know creating what the sets could  look like and working with the costume  stuff for a long time so he really knew  what his world looked like but we were  just missing that you know one important  element uh when one is making a feature  film and that's a completed script when  Ridley and I sat down together and we  went through it Page by Page and we  marked stuff that made no sense or that  was silly that you whittled it down to  26 Pages yeah it might have actually  been 22 now I think about it husband to  a murdered wife  and I will have my venues you know it's  the dumbest possible way to make a film  the dumbest possible we occasionally get  together and have a drink and laugh  about you know what sort of a bullet was  that we got not only did we get it done  it was the best film